so democrats are saying they won the
presidential election it's over you're
not allowed to talk about it anymore
they'll hurt you
if they do they're flooding our streets
they're victorious but the weird thing
is they're still angry
some of them seem madder than ever so
mad they want revenge for having to live
in a country with a president they
didn't vote for
in philadelphia this weekend a mob of
about a thousand joe biden voters beat
an
effigy of the sitting president why they
do that they say they just beat him
but they did sandy cortez called for
activists to quote
archive the name of trump's supporters
and then today
a well-funded democratic operation
funded mostly by
hedge fund managers and silicon valley
tycoons it's called the lincoln project
tweeted out personally identifying
information for the attorneys
representing the trump campaign
in voter fraud litigation quote here are
the two attorneys attempting to help
trump overturn the will of the
pennsylvanian people
they also encouraged lunatics to harass
attorneys at another prominent law firm
representing the pennsylvania republican
party make them famous
the lincoln project said how's it
different from hurt them
well of course it's not where is this
going and what's it about
tammy brewer is one of the most
insightful people on topics like this
we're happy to have her she's the host
of get tammy bruce on fox nation
tammy thanks for coming on so what why
when they say they've won
would they be even angrier and why
further still
would they be trying to get people they
disagree with hurt
well it's in their nature and we've seen
this play out actually before this
election
the riots right that is a signal of this
as well
is an effort and a desire to punish
people who are different
who accomplish something different from
you who maybe embarrassed you
who make you feel perhaps inadequate and
it's not you know their fault
but it's about this notion on the left
that any problem you have is due to
someone else
someone else did it to you and that's
going to have to manifest somehow
but all of these projects have resulted
in lists
and it's in media it's yes the lincoln
project another project was announced
after that
aoc tweet called the trump
accountability project
which is a list tucker of supreme court
justices
regular judges white house staff family
members
other politicians who assisted president
trump
it is literally a stalinistic tactic
and the making of lists in our history
of the
human history has never ended well
but it does provide us a stark alarm
about what people are capable of and
what they want to do
so when people have thought oh the
democrats and
and the people that hate trump and have
been doing all of this are well-meaning
they're just misguided
no no they're not well-meaning they know
what they're doing
these are smart political people they
understand the history of this
but they're doing it because they feel
they can and the american people
rejected it interestingly in this
election
down ballot it was a red wave and if
they continue on this
track of cancel culture and purge lists
the american people are going to give
them another kick in the bottom
in 2022 and also in georgia with those
two senators
people are going to be looking at these
runoff elections thinking is this what
we want
well i hope so because what's
interesting and alarming
is they weren't doing this last week or
last year
when they thought they had less power
the second they thought they
had control they became more extreme
shouldn't they calm down and be
magnanimous why are they doing this now
that that worries me
well well they've they've always wanted
to do it they're doing it now because
they feel that they'll be genuinely no
repercussions there'll be no problem
that they in fact maybe will be rewarded
i'm waiting to hear the biden campaign
kamala harris the obama campaign
everybody
condemn this repudiate it we have yet to
hear that
so we have this message of unity and
healing
but ignore the guillotine tucker because
that's a mostly peaceful machine
ah tammy i knew you'd explain it thank
you so much
great to see you thank you sir thank you